you may not be easily fooled but a
recent study showed that 1/3 of people
couldn't tell at a glance which of these
are masks sure they go by really fast
but when many people were given
unlimited time they still couldn't tell
when the given is as long as they'd like
they're having a really hard time and
giving us at the wrong answer to the
seemingly simple question on about 1 in
5 trials we've all seen masks like these
in movies like Mission Impossible but
they have made it out of Hollywood and
are being used to fool people in real
life and even commit crimes like this
masked bank robber in California the
police were looking for someone of a
particular description and it later
transpired that they'd been looking for
someone who is totally different so
learn more I spoke to rob Jenkins he's a
psychologist who has published studies
looking at facial perception using
hyper-realistic masks can you talk about
these experiments you've been running in
recent years looking at how these masks
are indeed fooling people
these hyper-realistic masks break the
connection that we've all become used to
between facial appearance and identity
and we were interested in whether people
are getting away with that kind of
concealment because people just aren't
paying attention they don't see any
reason to to be looking at the
particular person's face or maybe
they're just not expecting to see
something like a highly realistic mask
and so it doesn't occur to them that
that might be what they're seeing or if
the the masks really are so realistic
that they just pass for regular humans
and so we wanted to to test that more
formally we have this computer-based
tasks where we're showing people pairs
of images on screen and they just have
to say which one is the mask now we've
done that in in a couple of ways one is
just kind of at a glance so it's to
model the sort of situation where you
know if someone walks past we're talking
like a you know half a second or
something you just catch your eye
and we did that because we thought this
task might be too easy and weird to see
everyone's performing perfectly right
that wasn't the case at all
so people were terrible at making these
discriminations when it was a brief
presentation so we decided to make it
easier on them and just say okay you can
take as long as you like and when the
given is as long as they like that
improves performance a little bit but
they're having a really hard time and
giving us the wrong answer to the
seemingly simple question on about one
in five trials that's actually one of
the reasons I find this so interesting
is that we're evolutionarily programmed
to pick up on facial cues it's so much
of our social interaction yet you have
these mats that aren't necessarily
hundred percent realistic still fooling
a good amount of people humans are
social animals and so we rely very much
on getting whatever insight we can into
each other's mental states from from our
appearance so we can tell if someone's
following along in conversation we can
tell if they cross with us or pleased to
see us
or skeptical of what we're telling them
and and we need to do that we also need
to be able to connect it to particular
individuals so that when we see them
again we can remember what happened last
time and behave accordingly and this
isn't necessarily for fun and games
there's actually been some reports of
these being used in crimes to conceal
identity right we started to notice a
few years ago that we were seeing
reports in the news of things like bank
robberies where say the police were
looking for someone of a particular
description and it later transpired that
they'd been looking for someone who who
is totally different from the appearance
of the actual culprit so we're talking
things like totally different age maybe
different race different gender that
sort of thing and so you can see how
that kind of misleading of of the
investigation could really get things
off on the wrong path there was a case
in the United States where there was a
string of bank robberies that CCTV
footage show
appeared to be carried out by someone in
their 70s or 80s and this figure gained
a kind of antihero status online known
as the Geezer bandit and so people were
following him and you know to some
extent there was some cheering on of
this pensioner who was sticking it to
the man and he almost got caught on the
his final job so he was escaping on foot
from the scene of the crime and
apparently ran off at such great speed
that people watching started to wonder
if this really was someone in their 70s
or 80s and at that stage opinion so did
his shift towards okay well this looks
as if it could be someone much younger
wearing a mask that's putting us off the
scent I think what's really interesting
with that the bank robbery cases the
disconnect between what people thought
of for his face and what people thought
of for his ability to run which old
people don't do very well um how might
that just can I be playing out when
people are making these judgments about
how a person might be able to to move if
we want to improve detection of these
masks when they're being misused for
criminal activities part of the solution
might be to look for other cues that
conflict with the signal you're getting
from the face there could be mismatches
in a parent's age so if the way the
person is moving looks very youthful but
the face looks very old and wrinkled and
Haggard that's not a useful mismatching
cue so there are a number of things that
you could look for that are not directly
to do with facial appearance but
exploits the facial appearance in
conjunction with other messages that
you're getting and and that sort of
conflict could be a part of the
detection story I think these
hyper-realistic masks aren't anything
new we've seen them in the movies but
what seems to be new is that the price
has been coming down quite significantly
if you talk about maybe the evolution of
the industry here how this is becoming
more available for regular folks like us
I think this
started off in my Hollywood
special-effects industry and there are a
few craftsmen who were who were masters
of this particular form of artistry and
involved in sculpting and monster making
in all the rest of it and they developed
these techniques using various materials
over the years they started around six
hundred to a thousand maybe fifteen
hundred dollars so I have one here that
kind of an old favourite this one so as
you can see um it's made of this silicon
material so the coating is very durable
but also very flexible and it kind of
kind of looks like human skin in fact
which is the idea of course and it's not
what most people think of when they
think of a mask because it's a single
piece that goes right over the head down
the neck and over the shoulders so
there's no visible join at all so each
one is hand-painted everyone is unique
but you see all the all the details like
freckles and all the wrinkles there each
one is hand punched with human hair so
in this case eyebrows is a bit of bit of
ear hair there for added realism it's
another example I've got that has my
full head of hair all of these
developments over a number of years have
led to the position we're in now where
there were some manufacturers around the
world producing similar products along
those lines
and as a consequence the price has come
down a bit and and we're starting to see
these more widespread and they were
initially I mean you have clearly shown
that humans are not very good at picking
up these these masks but might that
actually pose a problem for facial
recognition our computers actually going
to be able to recognize these as fake
faces
although these hyper-realistic face
masks look a lot like real faces in in
the visible spectrum of light there are
other parts of the light spectrum you
could but
we play with so let's think about
infrared the thermal signature of a real
face is going to be quite different from
the thermal signature of a masked face
especially when that mask is made of
silicon because silicon is a very good
heat insulator right so you can imagine
if you had infrared vision which is a
problem for humans but not at all the
problem for automatic face recognition
systems that might just be a really
quick and simple way to tell well that's
not a real head that I'm looking at
because it's not glowing are there gaps
in the way that we as humans can
perceive faces this is a question that
that's kind of new to science and we
know that there's a range of ability in
identification tasks just telling who's
who some people are really really good
at that and in security in forensic
context there's increasing interest in
and be able to screen for those people
so that you can assign people to tasks
that involve face recognition who are
naturally good at that and tend not to
make mistakes whether you could do the
same with this new task of detecting
synthetic faces is is an open question
but it's one that we're looking into
thank you for showing us your real face
today that's what you think